rewind just a little bit okay when you
think about events in isolation just
think of the simplest example you can
let's go back to thinking about and I'm
okay now that example I always go back
to is just pick a number and I'ma pick a
number and die for me I have four boys
if I said something like this okay P 4
how do you read that in the context of
chance there's a probability of rolling
a four okay so far so good now if I said
in theoretical terms like in theory what
were the posi your answer would be yes
okay now just remind me 1 out of 6 where
is the one come from what what does it
mean because it's the favorable outcomes
and there's only a single four on the
face of the dial
yes and then the six current corresponds
to it yes very good at turtle events the
size of the sample space there are six
places you get now underneath this way
you've written this what I want to put
alongside this river I said I know what
did you think about eventual isolation I
want to think about that in relation to
other events so for instance if I posed
the parallel question if I said what's
the probability of not rolling a for now
don't just yell out the answer right
away I just want you to think about it
for a second how would I go about
answering this there's at least two ways
okay there's a long way a very
inefficient way and there's a better way
and the long way is what are the ways of
not rolling for what are the actual ways
thank you one two three five and six
okay so the probability of rolling not a
four is all of those probabilities do I
multiply them or do I add them I add
them right because really this is the
probability of one or two or three can
you wrap this with me or five or six and
when it's all or or you're adding these
these are separate they
happen all at the same time can I have a
1 in it all right
so unless you're on the place so because
there or is that means I can add that's
the probability of a 1 plus the
probability on the 2 and you get the
idea okay now that I've set it out and
hopefully you already worked out what
the answer is you can see where the
answer comes from right each of these is
just like the probability from the fall
if the diet is fair each one is a six
there's five of them so that's why the
answer of course is Isis okay so this is
fine and for a diet which only has six
alternatives I you actually can write
this out even though it's inefficient
but like I said there's a faster way
we're gonna do two things number one
instead of saying not for we're gonna
give a fancy dancer this we call it as
you can see by the heading the
compliment of four which basically means
not afford but we write it in this
particular way you put whatever event
you're interested in and then you put a
squiggle over the top okay so the way I
read that instead of saying the
probability of relative for this is the
probability of the complement or wrong
uniform which is exactly the same thing
as saying not for I can't do notice
right if you roll a four all you all are
not for that's all of the options right
that's the total sample space right so
what's the probability of rolling
something anything within the sample
space any of those options it's going to
be six out of six isn't it right so
that's why a six a sixth plus five six
is one says guarantee you're going to
get one of these right
so therefore the way I can write this if
these add up to one then rather than
just adding up all of these which takes
forever I can just subtract from one do
you see that the probability of the
complement of an event is the whole
probability take away the original one
you started with right you guys you see
the numbers that make sense right this
of course is one and take away
a sixth which gives you the five six we
had before this is much more handy when
you know maybe there's not six outcomes
maybe there are like 600 outcomes and
you don't want to write all of them even
if it wasn't 600 it might be something
simple like 52 okay I don't have to
write all 51 other options I just want
to write it in a nice efficient way okay
so this language here this idea if I can
generalize it a little bit a lot about
space over here on the right you can go
ahead and you can put this underneath if
I just don't want to get in the way of
my cards for any event and we usually
name our events eight for them right the
probability of that event not happening
that's the compliment right it's the
opposite the probability of that not
happening is one takeaway the poetry of
it actually happening does that make
sense
so this is the way an event and its
complement the way the probabilities
match up together okay now from that
sentence which is kind of like writing
this but not just for fours for anything
okay I can get through different
relationships out of that which I'd love
you to put underneath it you can either
say if you rearrange this equation just
the TEB for instance I could add this
probability of the event I could add it
to both sides right if I add it to both
sides over on the left I'll get this how
likely is the event happen
how likely is the event not to happen
they'd better add up to one
do you see that because look at the
disappear from the right-hand side all
alternatively in the same way that ever
at this if I think about the actual
event there's no probability of that
happening is one take away its
complement okay all three of these they
all say the same thing it's just that
we'll use different ones based on
whatever you want to do okay